Faites-vous confiance aux inconnus , votre mère vous à toujours dit de ne pas faire ça
Et elle a raison. Mes amis aujourd'hui on va faire une vidéo qui va pas être spécialement rigolote, mais qui me tient à coeur.
Il y a plein de trucs que j'aime bien dans la vie, et heureusement sinon je me ferais chier, et l'une de ces choses est la sociologie.
Étudier les comportements humains et les faits sociaux c'est passionnant, je trouve !
Je suis tombé sur un jeu qui s'appelle "The Evolution of Trust"
L'évolution de la confiance. Et je trouve que c'est hyper intéressant parce que, aujourd'hui on est dans une société où il y a de plus en plus d'égoïsme, enfin..
C'est la pensée générale. On est tous un peu méfiants les uns les autres même si des fois ya pas trop de raison de l'être, enfin voilà
Ce jeu a été créé par un mec qui nous montre pourquoi les choses sont devenues comme ça.
C'est parti, play. Pendant la première guerre mondiale, c'était la fin de la paix. Il s'est passé un truc assez remarquable le Noël 1914 sur le front.
Ah je pense que vous connaissez cette histoire, moi je la connais ! En dépit de l'interdiction formelle de sympathiser avec l'ennemi, les soldats anglais et
allemands ont quittés leurs tranchées, ont traversé le No man's land.. Donc le No man's land c'est la zone entre les deux tranchées, où il y a les échanges de balles quoi
Donc si un mec est là il décède immédiatement, ils se sont rassemblés pour enterrer leurs morts,
s'échanger des cadeaux et jouer à des jeux. en plein temps de guerre vous imaginez pendant ce temps là nous sommes en
2017 ça fait des décennies que l'occident est en période de paix mais n'a jamais été aussi méfiants les sondages montrent que sur ces 40
dernières années les gens mentent de plus en plus donc voici notre énigme pourquoi en temps de paix les amis deviennent des ennemis et pourquoi
en temps de guerre les ennemis deviennent des amis
j'aime trop ce genre de truc j'espère que je vais réussir dans cette vidéo à vous faire aimer ça parce que franchement il ya de quoi être hub à
toi d'un objectif je pense que la théorie des jeux peut expliquer d'autres épidémies de la méfiance et comment on peut arranger ça pour comprendre
tout ça jouons à un jeu voilà c'est parti le jeu de la confiance ok donc la il a fait un petit jeu pour qu'on
comprenne mieux ce délire de la méfiance et de la confiance tu as un choix en face de toi ya une machine si tu mets
une pièce dans la machine
l'autre joueur va recevoir trois pièces et vice versa si lui aussi met une pièce tu vas aussi en recevoir 3
vous pouvez tous les deux choisir de
coopérer donc mettre une pièce ou de tricher ne pas mettre de pièces imagine que l'autre joueur triche est ne mette pas de pièce qu'est ce
que tu vas faire
bah je vais coopérer puis l'insulté sur sa page Facebook en lui disant que c'est un gros lâche c'est faux si on est certains qu'il triche
on va tricher aussi on va dire qu'on a le droit c'est logique vous êtes d'accord
exactement pourquoi tu le laisserais te berner si tu coopères et qu'il triche tu vas perdre une pièce pendant que lui va en gagner trois injustice
toutefois si vous trichez tous les deux bah aucun de vos va gagner ou perdre quoi que ce soit score 0 vs 0
morales t'as intérêt à tricher c'est l'autre triche
ok maintenant disons que l'autre joueur
coopère et quil m'et une pièce qu'est ce que tu vas faire tu va coopérer jusque là tout est parfaitement logique et c'est ce qu'on
ferait tous bien sûr ça a l'air d'être le choix le plus juste
à moins que ça ne soit pas si vous coopérez tous les deux vous dépensez chacun une pièce pour en gagner trois mais si tu triches
alors qu'il coopère tu vas gagner trois pièces et lui il en aura perdu une donc tu devrais toujours triché et voici donc notre
dilemme la confiance c'est bien mais ça permet aux autres de prendre un avantage sur toi où ça leur permet de te tirer dessus quand tu sors
non armé d'une tranchée comme en noël
1914 parfois la méfiance est rationnelle maintenant voyons ce qui se passe quand on joue à ce jeu plusieurs fois ooh
mec j'aime trop c'est trop bien jusque là ils
ont 100% raison c'est la vérité maintenant jouons pour de vrai tu vas jouer contre cinq adversaires
différents chacun avec sa propre stratégie
avec chaque opposant tu vas jouer entre trois et sept fois d'affilée et tu ne seras pas en avance quel round est le dernier
vas tu leur faire confiance
ou alors peuvent-ils te faire confiance alala 'tain
ok mise en pratique de ce qu'il vient de dire on est contre un inconnu on sait pas ce qui va faire on commence on cheat ou
on coopère moi j'aurais tendance à coopérer au début je sais pas si c'est un fils de plus dans le doute je coopère
ok il a coopéré aussi on est bien j'ai coopéré il a coopéré il n'y a aucune raison de se mettre à tricher maintenant alors on
on recoopère il recoopère aussi c'est parfait on va recoopéré il recoopère perd aussi c'est parfait
ok fin du premier cas de figure le mec en face coopérer et à chaque fois je coopérer à chaque fois tout s'est bien
passé ok nouvel adversaire je coopère
au le fils de ... on va tricher
ah le batard il triche aussi on va tricher ils triche aussi
voilà bilan des courses on a perdu une pièce et on en a gagné trois nouvelles personnes on va coopérer
tout se passe bien
Et là on aurait tendance à se dire putain la partie d'avant je me suis fait niquer pourquoi moi je niquerais pas cette personne à
son tour pour récupérer ce que j'ai perdu donc on va tricher
ooh la pauvre ça me brise le coeur
ooh non c'est horrible, on l'arnaque. ok nouveau perso on va tricher
Maintenant on va coopérer
ok il nous a berné on a donc gagné 2 pièces chacun on arrête les conneries on coopère maintenant
enculé! il fait que tricher c'est un bâtard
C'est un bâtard
Alors ton score est de 31 le score le plus bas c'est 7 et le plus haut c'est 49 donc qui étaient ces étranges personnages
contre qui tu viens de jouer d'accord donc il fait une liste des cinq personnalités
possible donc vous allez sûrement vous reconnaître parmi l'une de ces cinq personnalités premiers caractères possible l'imitateur c'est celui qui commençait en
coopérant et qui ensuite
copier tout ce que je faisais tu avais celui qui faisait que tricher j'espère que personne ne s'est reconnu tu as celle qui faisait que
coopérer 4e  caractère c'estcelui qui grogne c'est celui qui commençait par coopérer et si je trichais une fois contre lui il trichait sur tous les rounds
qui suivaient et le dernier c'est le détective il va m'analyser il va commencer par
coopérer ensuite il va cheaté une fois et ensuite il va coopérer deux fois ci après ça je triche une fois il va se mettre à
faire comme le mec qui copie si je triche pas il va faire comme celui qui triche tout le temps pour m'exploiter. ooh l'enculé !
maintenant voyons si chacun de ces caractères jouaient
les uns contre les autres c'est intéressant on va mettre du coup tous les profils l'un contre l'autre c'est un tournoi chaque perso va maintenant
jouer contre l'autre ça fait un total de dix matchs et dix rounds par match
ok c'est le moment des pronostics selon vous quel caractère va obtenir le plus de pièces celui qui coopèrent tout le temps il va forcément
être perdant parce qu'en face quand ça va tricher lui va continuer de coopérer tu comprends celui qui fait que tricher
bah ça va marcher que au premier round et les neuf rounds d'après la personne en face va tricher aussi parce qu'elle va bien
comprendre que ç'est fdp donc ça va être entre le gruger et le détective et le grunge heures je rappelle celui qui va commencer
en coopérant et qui va continuer de coopérer tant que je coopère par contre dès que je vais cheaté il va cheaté jusqu'à la fin de
la game je pense que c'est le détective parce ce qu'au final il va exploiter la personne faible vous avez vu j'ai dit la personne faible
alors que c'est ouf en disant ça je pense à la personne qui va faire que de coopérer mais elle n'est pas faible elle est juste bienveillante
donc il va exploiter la personne bienveillante et il va savoir contrer la personne malveillante donc c'est forcément le détective pour moi qui va gagner
ok maintenant voyons les matchs un par un et voyons comment ça se passe premier match
l'imitateur contre celui qui triche tout le temps et bah l'imitateur se fait avoir au premier round mais à tous les rounds d'après il ne se fait plus avoir
deuxième round l'imitateur contre celui qui fait que coopérer eh ben ils gagnent tous les deux 20  troisième round
l'imitateur contre celui qui grogne ils gagnent tous les deux 20 aussi quatrième round l'imitateur contre le détective
l'imitateur va tricher une fois quand le détective va tricher lors du deuxième round bilan ils gagnent chacun 18 pièces cinquième match celui qui triche
contre celui qui coopère tout le temps celui qui triche ressort gagnant de 30 pièces ooh et celui qui coopère tout le temps il en
a perdu 10 ooh
c'est triste celui qui coopère tout le temps contre le détective et bah il se fait manger parce que le détective comprends qu'il ait trop
de bonne foi et va l'arnaqué encore et encore du coup celui qui coopère perd 1 et le détective gagne 27 fdp
bref je vous épargne tout ça c'est un peu long
ooh c'est celui qui copie tout le temps qui ressort le plus gagnant de tout ça donc
l'imitateur passe par de nombreux nom la règle d'or l'altruisme réciproque ou encore vivre et laisser vivre
c'est pour ça que la paix est apparu ce soir de noël dans les tranchées de la première guerre mondiale quand vous êtes force à
jouer le même jeu avec les mêmes personnes spécifiques encore et encore et pas avec l'ennemi générique et bah l'imitateur ne gagne pas juste la bataille
il gagne la guerre
mais si les choses changent quand tu joues encore et encore au même jeu voyons voir ce qui se passe quand on joue
plusieurs tournois olala ça part en steaks oh putain c'est indécent maintenant laissons notre population de joie
évoluer à travers le temps c'est une danse en trois temps premièrement on joue un tournoi
laissons-les tout jouer les uns contre les autres et comptons leur score 2 on élimine les losers on dégage les 5 plus mauvais joueur
s'il ya une égalité choisis en un au pif entre eux ooh tristesse 3 on
reproduit les gagnants ont clone les cinq meilleurs joueurs et on refait ça autant qu'on le voudra donc à chaque fois on va faire un
tournoi on va éliminer les 5 plus mauvais et on va cloner les cinq meilleurs à la fin il n'en restera qu'un, qu'une seule catégorie
de personnes voyons ça en actions disons qu'on commence avec une population de 25 personnes parmi elle il y en a 15 qui font que de
coopérer 5 qui font que tricher et cinq qui sont des imitateurs
je pense c'est ce qu'ils coopèrent tout le temps qui vont dégager forcément mais celui qui triche tout le temps c'est évident qu'ils gagnent contre
ceux qui coopèrent tout le temps mes est ce qu'il gagne contre celui qui imite aah je sais pas bon voyons la réponse c'est quoi
Du coup on se retrouve avec 10 tricheurs dix personnes qui coopèrent tout le temps et 5 imitateur maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe qu'on
quand on refait un tournoi
eh ben je crois que c'est exactement pareil on élimine les cinq pires donc c'était le caractère qui coopère tout le temps et on
reproduit le 5 meilleurs c'est ceux qui trichent tout le temps
ouais mais quoi ils vont se retrouver entre eux ils vont être baiser ils vont gagner
000 c'est ça l'histoire ben voilà exactement c'est ce qui commence à se passer là ils ont gagné 165 pièces chacun c'est autant que les
imitateurs alors que celui qui coopère tout le temps il a gagné que 30 ooh
reproduisons 5 du top 5 et ça nous donne 6 imitateur pour
19 tricheurs du coup les imitateurs vont petit à petit reprendre le tube parce que quand tu mets des tricheurs entre eux
eh ben ils gagnent plus rien parce que quand tu triches compte un tricheur tu gagne rien et c'est ce qui se passe entre
c'est intéressant donc on vient de faire le 4e tournoi et on peut voir que les six meilleurs scores sont les imitateurs donc tu va dégager
5 tricheurs parmi les 19 qui sont les cinq pires joueurs et tu va dupliquer
les cinq meilleurs qui sont des imitateurs les tricheurs deviennent victimes de leur propre succès il
exploite la naïveté de ceux qui coopèrent tout le temps mais une fois qu'il ya plus du tout des gens pour coopérer et ben ils
font face aux imitateurs qui sont des gens bons mais pas naïf on continue il se passe la même chose
parce que les imitateurs entre eux gagnent
masse thune alors que les tricheurs quand ils trichent contre un imitateur bas ça marche pas et donc on va finir avec une population
d'imitateur les tricheurs on gagné sur une courte période mais son exploitabilité a mené à sa chute
au revoir
tricheur bilan il semble que les
mathématiques de la théorie des jeux nous raconte quelque chose la philosophie de l'imitateur correspond donc au faites aux autres ce que vous voudriez qu'ils
vous fassent c'est beau
toutefois au putain y a couille en pâté si la stratégie de l'imitateur dans ce jeu qu'on a répété plusieurs fois et si puissante tellement puissante
qu'elle a amené les soldats dans les tranchées de la première guerre mondiale
à indépendamment mettre au point la même stratégie à savoir la stratégie du vivre et laisser vivre
on en est arrivé à un point où les gens n'ont plus confiance et ne sont plus dignes de confiance
qu'est ce qui a causé cette épidémie de manque de confiance on va donc répéter le même jeu mais cette fois il ya
vingt-trois personnes qui coopèrent tout le temps un tricheur et un imitateur start
Donc on vient de voir que en faisant dix rounds par match il ne reste plus que l'imitateur mais quand tu changes le nombre de rounds
ça change tout si tu mets qu'un round par exemple logiquement le tricheur à le temps de berner
l'imitateur parce que l'imitateur n'a pas le temps d'imiter le mec qui trichent voilà et comme tu viens de le découvrir par toi même
moins il y a d'interactions répétés entre des individus plus la méfiance va se répandre génial mais il existe une autre manière de susciter la méfiance
habituellement
l'imitateur gagne mais changeons le gain généré quand deux personnes coopèrent
habituellement ils gagnent chacun deux pièces faisant en sorte qu'ils n'en gagnent qu'une on va mettre en plus un du coup
eh ben les tricheurs se répandent énormément la même chose se produit avec une récompense
gagnant-gagnant
inférieur donc quand les deux coopère le tricheur prend le relais c'est triste c'est à dire que même si il n'y a que des gens qui coopèrent
y gagner au final moins de pièces qu'un tricheur
la théorie des jeux à deux idées puissante à ce sujet le jeu du zéro somme c'est la conviction malheureusement commune qu'un gain pour nous
doit venir à la perte d'un autre et vice versa
c'est vrai souvent quand tu gagnes un truc tu dis que l'autre bas il a perdu quelque chose et le jeu à somme nulle c'est
quand les gens font un gros effort pour créer un jeu gagnant gagnant où au moins d'éviter
le perte perte tu sens le jeu à somme nulle la confiance ne peut évoluer bien évidemment pas ce que tu dis que si
tu gagnes un truc c'est que l'autre a perdu quelque chose dont tu vas devenir tricheurs finalement c'est triste aussi cool qu'avec l'imitateur il y a
une énorme faiblesse fatale que je n'ai pas encore mentionné pour comprendre le problème disons que deux imitateurs joue les uns contre les autres étant
des bons joueurs ton premier moove va être de coopérer bien évidemment à partir de là normalement ils vont juste chacun coopérer à chaque fois mais
que faire si en essayant de réciproquer la bonté y ce passe quoi
Oh non ! les erreurs la mauvaise communication et la mauvaise interprétation
sont des accidents qui arrivent tout le temps dans la vraie vie mais si l'autre personne ne pense pas que c'était un accident alors il
va tricher la fois d'après
Au nom pour la deuxième fois cette fois c'est l'autre qui est déçu
et vu que c'est lui aussi un imitateur et ben il va tricher et donc les deux vont chacun tricher à
l'infini voilà il a suffi d'un élément pour que pouf ça nique tout
Les amis ,  petite ellipse. On a refait l'expérience avec de nouveaux caractères, c'était assez intéressant
Mais ça va prendre beaucoup de temps à expliquer alors qu'au final le raisonnement est le même
La théorie des jeux nous a montré trois choses dont nous avons besoin pour l'évolution de la confiance
-Premièrement : des interactions répétés entre les mêmes individus
-Deuxièmement :  ils faut joué à un jeu sans somme nulle donc un jeu gagnant gagnant
voilà et pas un jeu où il y a un gagnant et un perdant
-Troisièmement : il faut qu'ils y aient le moins d'erreur de communication possible entre les deux
parce que si le niveau d'erreur de communication est trop haut alors le niveau de confiance va chuter
Mais quand il y a peu d'erreur de communication alors les gens arrivent à pardonner et y a pas de souci
Inutile de rappeler que dans le monde dans lequel on vit il y a bien plus de facteur que ça
comme la réputation le partage des valeurs, les contrats, les marqueurs culturels, etc
Maintenant la conclusion finale, ce qu'il faut retenir de tout ça : Ce que le jeu est défini ce que les joueurs vont faire
Le problème aujourd'hui c'est pas simplement que les joueurs perdent confiance
c'est que notre environnement agit contre l'évolution de la confiance
ça peut sembler cynique ou naïf que nous sommes simplement des produits de notre environnement
Mais comme le théorie des jeux nous le rappelle, nous sommes l'environnement de chacun
À court terme, le jeu définie les joueurs mais à long terme ce sont nous les joueurs qui définissent le jeu
WHAT ELSE ! Donc quand on commence à être ripou le jeu devient ripou et on est ripou et le jeu devient ripou et ça s'arrête plus
Donc faites ce que vous pouvez faire pour créer les conditions nécessaire à l'évolution de la confiance
Établissez des relations, trouvez les victoires, communiquer clairement
Peut-être que nous pouvons arrêter de tirer les uns contre les autres, sortir de nos propres tranchées, traversé No Man's Land pour venir ensemble et apprendre à vivre et à laisser vivre
Ah ouiiiiii !!! J'ai beaucoup aimé, alors c'était facile pour moi comme vidéo j'avait juste à lire ce que ce mec qui lui est un génie a écrit
mais tu comprends mieux pourquoi on en est arrivé, pourquoi ça s'arrange pas
et comment on peut faire à notre échelle pour que petit à petit on rendent les gens autours de nous meilleurs qui rendent les gens autours d'eux meilleurs pour qui rendent les gens autours d'eux meilleurs
Et ce qui fait qu'on va redéfinir les règles du jeu et le jeu sera plus gagnant gagnant et nous serons de meilleurs personnes
C'est beau putain, j'ai aimé. Bah n’hésitait pas à aimé la vidéo si ça vous a plus, un peu de sociologie comme ça
vous savez maintenant pourquoi les gens ne se font plus confiance bon a part nous parce qu'on est proche voilà tout ça
J'(vous dit??) a tous dans une prochaine vidéo qui sera drôle nous vous enfaîtes pas
Là j'avais vraiment envie de faire un petit peu de sociologie ça faisait longtemps
Et je sais plus qui ma parlait de ce truc là mais ça ma tout de suite intéresser j'suis très content d'avoir oser faire cet vidéo. J'vous dit à bientôt dans une prochaine, salut !
Sous-titres par TheLostLeGamer, El H, BIGz H2O, Enoha Sulinger et JimmyTheTest